hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
near the end of his treatise on virtues
and vices which is addressed to a
nobleman count guy who alcoin
calls his dearest son there's a
discussion of what we call the cardinal
virtues and here we're naming the four
virtues that come up from plato onward
in a lot of moral philosophy and virtue
ethics and alchemin of york is framing
these in terms of
remedies for the eight capital vices but
also some
you could say dispositions that we human
beings need to have within ourselves if
we indeed want to enjoy
happiness eternal blessedness all these
things that the christian life is
supposed to be aiming for it's good to
remember that alcuin himself is a monk
and he's drawing upon a long long
history of previous virtue ethics both
pagan and christian
and so the thing that he starts out with
is saying well we need to say what a
virtue is and he's not providing a you
know massive discussion here this is a
kind of summary of what it is from his
perspective that virtues are and so the
first thing he tells us is that a virtue
is a habit habitus in latin of the mind
and a habit
is something that we develop over time
so these virtues of you know practical
wisdom or prudence
justice fortitude or courage temperance
or moderation these are not just things
that we do
they are dispositions or habits that
have been developed within the mind and
he doesn't go into any discussion about
how that takes place here
although you know again there's a vast
long discussion leading up to alko and
about how that happens so this is pretty
standard fare for what a virtue is in
virtue ethics the other things that he
says about it are very interesting and
this gives us an idea about how he's
centering the virtues within moral life
but specifically within a christian
framework so he tells us that the second
thing an ornament dekus of nature it's
it's a way in which
human nature is made beautiful is made
fit is developed in the way that it
ought to be then he says that it's a
reason of life errazio
and
razio here can mean more than just a
reason like you know i give you a reason
why are you going to the store well i
need to buy some milk it's more like a
structure a rational structure a way of
articulating
and arranging and prioritizing
how things ought to go within
one's life so it's an arrangement of
one's life if you like and then he says
another thing really interesting the
piety
of morals now morals here is translating
the word morum that's the word we get
morality from when we talk about the
more ace the customs
the
norms of a particular group or you know
more generally
so
this is closely connected to
habits habits and mores
are
interconnected and so the piety
of them piety means an orientation
towards the divine you know so being
rightly oriented in one's mores in one's
customs in one's habits
and it's also you know
you could think about it going both ways
here it's a way in which by
having the
right mores we are pious we express that
other uh morphs or you know that's the
singular for it
of piety another kind of habit
the adoration of the godhead okay now
this is very clearly within a religious
framework right and these virtues are a
way in which we
worship
and this is you know taking us quite far
from earlier conceptions of virtue where
it might be pleasing to the gods this is
a way in which we actually
properly arrange ourselves in relation
to
god then he says the honor of a human
being owner hominis right so this is not
uh gender specific homo means human
being not just man right so it includes
everybody
the honor the proper
what would we call it you know this is
closely related to uh honest the you
know integrity of a human being and then
finally the merit of eternal beatitude
through the virtues through having the
virtues and acting on the virtues and
opposing them to the vices as we're
going to talk about in a moment we merit
the greatest kind of happiness available
within the christian framework that is
eternal beatitude after death of course
but you know perhaps also in this life
to some degree some happiness some
blessedness beatitudo means happiness or
blessedness
so this is a pretty
substantive conception of what a virtue
is it's not just a habit it's not just
things that are socially approved
they do in fact lead us to
happiness or merit happiness but they
also express the
proper relation of a human being to
their own nature
and to their capacity for reasoning for
arranging their life and to
the divine now
that already tells us why a human being
would need the virtues
but there's a little passage just before
this in the discussion of the eight
capital vices which are going to
eventually turn into the seven deadly
sins as well but alcuin is retaining
this discussion of the eight capital
vices that is coming from ivagrius
ponticus and john cassian two important
monastic authors and he tells us that
the
vices are actually opposed so the vices
are leaders dukase right they are um
captains as it's talked about in
gregory's morality on job which alcohol
knows quite well
and these
leaders of the vices are opposed by
virtues so he tells us there
pride is opposed through humility greed
through abstinence fornication through
chastity
avarice through wisdom
anger through patience weariness through
constancy of good works bad sadness
through spiritual joy vainglory through
the charity of god now that sounds like
there's
eight virtues opposing them doesn't it
he goes on immediately and says
therefore
also four very glorious leaders
command these commanders
through the christian religion whom we
oppose to the warriors of diabolical
impiety and the names of these uh
leaders of leaders are these prudence
justice courage
and temperance so
um in this treatise there have been a
number of different
virtues or we could call them fruits of
the virtues disgust you know that begins
with wisdom and faith charity
goes on to all sorts of other
virtues as well
all of these can be understood in a
certain sense according to alcuin
as falling under these cardinal virtues
and this is a rather distinctive
way to go because in some other
christian accounts you've got the four
cardinal virtues and then you have you
know for example the three theological
virtues of faith hope and charity and
those aren't found in
these four cardinal virtues so you wind
up with seven virtues uh monastic
authors will often add humility itself
as a very important virtue as opposed to
you know the vice of pride
so maybe there's eight or something like
that alchemin is actually telling his
correspondent count guy
no no properly understood the cardinal
virtues actually include these other
christian theological however you want
to frame them virtues so what what do
each of these encompass
he talks about prudence first and he
calls it the knowledge of divine
and human things just as is given to a
person
by which is to be understood what is to
be avoided or what is to be done by a
person and this is what we read in the
psalm turn from evil and do good so it
sounds like prudence prudencia is
practical wisdom as opposed to any sort
of other kind of wisdom like sapientia
in latin but we go on and we find that
he actually tells us there is no better
wisdom
than that by which god is known
according to the measure of the human
mind and feared and his future judgment
believed what is more just than to
please okay so we go on from there but
notice that wisdom
prudencia is going to encompass
these other things that we see discussed
at the very beginning of the treaties on
virtues and vices what about justice
eustitia
so he calls it interestingly nobilitas
nobility of mind
and
this is something that we would actually
normally associate with
courage you know magnaminity greatness
of mind but he actually places this
under justice and so he says it gives
its own dignity
to each and every matter now what does
that mean to give its own dignity
dignitas in in latin well this is a
medieval
term
that is used in a lot of treatises and
it means basically what the thing
deserves
what it merits how it fits into the
grand scale
of things so giving the dignity to each
matter includes
prioritizing things properly giving each
person
what it is
that they deserved and so he goes on and
says in this adoration of the godhead so
part of justice would be
orientation to god right
and the laws of humanity okay so that's
part of justice and just judgments right
not unjust judgments following just
judgments and equity of all life
is preserved so this is what justice
includes and he goes on a little bit
later and tells us what is more just
than to please god and keep his
commandments through whom while we were
not we were created while we were lost
we were recreated and freed from
diabolical servitude and who gave to us
all good things that we have so placing
things in a proper framework
is not merely a secular matter of
justice justice applies both to the
world of the everyday but also to
the divine as well
then we have courage now remember
he is writing to a guy who belongs to a
warrior class count guy
and here he's not stressing battlefield
courage at all he's stressing other
aspects of courage that christian and
even non-christian authors like for
example the stoics
highlighted
so fortitudo courage he tells us
fortitude is great patience of the mind
and long-sufferingness
and perseverance and good work and
victory against all forms of vices
courage is what we need when things get
tough courage is what we need when we
start to get bored or oppressed or we
find ourselves out of our elements so
courage requires patience perseverance
long sufferingness and it's turned
against the vices and he says what is
better than by this fortitude to conquer
the devil and overcome all his
suggestions and bravely
bear all adversities of the world for
the sake of god's name so courage itself
is turned in a theological direction
then we have temperance temperancia
which he says is a very great virtue and
why does he say that because perhaps
some people think it's ah
you know that's the the fourth it's not
really that important but he thinks it's
incredibly
important temperation is moderation of
all life right
so that a person does not love
or
hate something excessively but regulates
all varieties of this life with
considered
carefulness and he uses
delegancia there right
and consideratio
those are both important here temperance
is not just like sticking to the middle
path it's actually thinking things
through
and making the right decisions about
these sorts of things and then a little
bit later he says so it's a very noble
virtue
through which all honor of this life
remains among people so that a person
may think
speak and be led temperately
in every case
whatever right so this is a part of that
rule
reason
of life so these four virtues encompass
all of the virtues that are being
discussed in the treaties on virtues and
vices and they oppose all of the capital
vices that are getting in the way of
living a properly
rational human life
you